domestic violence and sexual assault
unfortunately our nation still lags in
providing fundamental safeguards
for women and girls against violence
in 1994 congress included the right to
sue one's attacker
in vawa but when a woman named christy
brampala
tried to exercise that right the supreme
court dismissed her case
and deemed the provision
unconstitutional
women must be in the constitution
to enforce their rights to sue to
protect themselves
unfortunately we're seeing the effects
of gender inequality
during the pandemic with me both more
reports of domestic violence
greater wage and unemployment
disparities
between men and women an estimated one
million more women than men
have lost their jobs since the coveted
pandemic
was declared a year ago and the biggest
impact of the virus
has been on the vast mach majority of
essential workers
must of whom are women and
disproportionately
the number of black women and latinas
nearly all of whom have the majority of
caregiving responsibilities
these trends along with other tragic
realities
make constitutional rights for women
more urgent
than ever by ending sex discrimination
and cementing equality of rights under
the law and the constitution
we can finally make good on a hundred
year old promise
it's time to spell out equality in the
constitution with three
words era equality has no limit
i thank my colleague jackie speer
our leader our speaker the women's
caucus jerry
navarre and everyone here today and i
now
uh represent the co-chair of the dwc
uh
i want to thank my co-chair uh
jackie spears for her leadership and my
committee chair
uh miss maloney for all your hard work
we're here during women's history month
to reaffirm our commitment
for doing better to support our women
and girls
i want to say how incredibly proud i am
to be on the floor today to pass the
equal rights amendment resolution
to remove this time limit can we really
look our daughters and our sisters and
our mothers
and our nieces in the face and say i'm
sorry there's a time
to you getting equality in america
no i'm not going to have that
conversation for far
too long women in the united states have
been denied
equality and this pandemic has only
worsened
that equality especially for women of
color
we have borne the brunt of this pandemic
and we have a system in america that's
so often suppress
and also do not support women we have
heard so many people during women's
history month reconfirm their commitment
to do better in supporting women and
girls this
is how we do it by fighting for
era by fighting sex discrimination
making
gender equality the law of the land
it's unacceptable that we are having
this conversation or discussion in 2021
but one thing about women we will
continue to fight we will not back down
we know that the soul and the moral of
this country rests on the shoulders of
women
like it has for centuries and i'm proud
to stand today
with the women of the women's caucus to
make a difference
38 states have now ratified the era
this is a historic time for our country
and
congress decides what's next and i am so
proud of that and i want to turn it over
to my other co-chair
and that is um miss franco from florida
thank you
thank you thank you honor to be with my
colleagues here
i posed this question what do the
following
women have in common teacher
melissa palowski who saved 19 children
during the massacre at marjory stoneman
stoneman douglas high school
senator tammy duckworth who lost both
her legs in a combat
mission in iraq alice augustine
a chemist who revolutionized the
treatment
for leprosy joe harjo the first native
american poet laureate
dolores herta civil rights activist
the majority of essential workers as we
come back home with including
nearly nine out of ten nurses
and two-thirds of the workers at grocery
store check out the fast food counters
what do they have in common no matter
the sacrifice of contributions to
society if you are a woman
or a girl in the united states of
america you are not
guaranteed equality under the law
it took women 144 years from
the birth of our nation to get the right
to vote
even longer for women of color it took
197 years to gain the legal right to an
abortion
198 years to be able to buy a home
in our own name and now after 245 years
have passed since the birth of our
nation isn't it time
to pass equal rights amendment the
united states house of representatives
took an important step
forward today i applaud everybody who
helped make that happen
and i urge the united states senate to
join us
and i know that
[Music]
thank you let me just conclude by saying
this
i know we're running out of time i will
be very sustained
i i want to recognize the incredible
powerhouse
of women that i have the privilege to
serve with
in the democratic women's caucus um and
we we have these amazing women
leading the way and i'm just so humbled
to be standing beside them
and working beside them i want to add
just a couple of details
to the context that my colleagues have
provided you
there are structures in place that are
deliberately placed there
to prevent women from achieving
everything that we can
there is not just discrimination
against us because of our gender but
because we have babies
there's pregnancy discrimination it's we
have
unequal pay and then when it's time to
re-enter the workforce
after raising families or taking being
caregivers to family members
we face additional obstacles and
hardships along the way
and it is because we are not an equal
member of society in the same way that
men are
and i will say that minority women
suffer
even greater disparities latina women
as an example um earn 53 cents
on the dollar for every dollar that a
white man earns in america
53 cents on the dollar so it should not
be a surprise why minority women
especially black and brown women in
america
are often spiral into poverty more
quickly
they have more barriers to health care
and to education
and so the the work that our foremothers
and
our colleagues did to get us to that
moment
this moment right now our daughters our
granddaughters
the women that we work with every single
day your mothers your sisters
we will finally finally at the end of
this journey
once this becomes law we will finally
achieve the equality that we deserve
thank you so much manager
let me just close with this the pandemic
has created a situation where 2.3
million women have lost their jobs
permanently thousands and thousands of
childcare slots have been lost
but it is time for us to stop with the
excuses
it is time for us to do what's right in
this country
and make sure that women are in the
constitution
of the united states we implore our
senate colleagues
to do the right thing you represent
53 of the population it's time to just
make us equal
under the law thank you thank you
there's no questions left
in here
that's what i was told sorry i can talk
to you outside
thank you
oh